the top lawyer for the National Security
Council as well as mr. Blair from the
office of management budget and someone
worked closely with Mick Mulvaney both
of them defied congressional subpoenas
and refused to appear for their
scheduled depositions as has been the
case with other witnesses who have done
the same thing this will be further
evidence of an effort by the
administration to obstruct the lawful
and constitutional duties of Congress I
would also say and we expect the
witnesses who have been subpoenaed to
come in this afternoon at why status
instruction also to be no-shows this
will only further add to the body of
evidence on a potential obstruction of
Congress charge against the president
indeed in the Nixon impeachment there
was an article of impeachment based on
the obstruction of Congress that
itemized each of the subpoenas that the
White House had defied well today we
have four additional subpoenas to add to
the list of a potential charge involving
the president ID States and his
obstruction of our constitutional duties
these witnesses are significant in the
White House understands they're
significant based on the testimony of
the committee the committees have
already received we know that these
witnesses those that were in the law
office of the National Security Council
those who worked for Mulvaney either in
the chief of staff's office or the
office of management budget are
firsthand witnesses to allegations of
serious misconduct both visa vie the
suspension of military aide and the
effort to use that aid as a lever to get
ukraine to do these political
investigations to help the president's
reelection campaign but also in efforts
to potentially hide the evidence of the
president's misconduct by placing that
call record in a classified system that
would be on V beyond most individuals
access and a system in which that call
record did not belong so very pertinent
testimony very relevant to the other
witnesses have come forward and we may
infer by the White House obstruction
here that
their testimony would be further
incriminating of the president I will
say this it's quite obvious and fully we
fully expected this we have seen a
series of shifting ever-changing
rationales for this campaign of
obstruction first there was the argument
we won't comply don't have to comply
until there's a formal vote on the House
floor well we had a formal vote on the
House floor then it was we don't have to
make these witnesses available because
they're senior officials and they're
given absolute immunity even though no
court has ever upheld the claims of
absolute immunity indeed the only one to
reach a decision on it involving Harriet
Miers ruled there is no such thing as
absolute immunity and it's been the
uniform position of Democrats and
Republicans that we do not respect any
fallacious claims of absolute immunity
but then when people who were subpoenaed
had little or no interaction with the
President and there couldn't be even a
colorable claim of some kind of immunity
the explanation shifted once again to
well we're not gonna let them come
forward because you won't let agency
lawyers present and again that would
violate the house deposition rules it
would also violate the practice used by
both Democrats and Republicans for
depositions in the past when there are
concerns that agency lawyers are
representing agencies that it may have
been gauged in wrongdoing or may use
facts gained in the investigation to
prejudice other witnesses in the
investigation this was the practice for
the current members of our investigative
committees people like Jim Jordan during
Benghazi and people like Mike Pompeo and
people like Mike Mick Mulvaney all
participated in depositions of senior
agency officials without the presence of
agency counsel so if they join the
president's objection here they do so in
fashion that is directly contradictory
to their practices when they were in the
majority today we also are beginning the
process of releasing transcripts of our
depositions this morning released the
depositions of the pastor McKinley
ambassador
and ambassador Jovanovic and i will
leave you all to review those
transcripts there are a few things that
will become immediately clear when you
do and the first is that contrary to the
claims of the president and his acolytes
on the hill that these have been
proceedings in which the Republicans
have not been able to be present or ask
questions in fact Republicans were
present for all of these depositions and
in fact they had equal opportunity with
Democrats to ask questions and you will
see they took full advantage of those
opportunities to ask questions you will
see in ambassador jovanovic a--'s
testimony what a dedicated public
servant she is this is someone who
served the country with distinction for
decades it is someone who also is one of
the first witnesses to this irregular
back-channel that the president
established with Rudy Giuliani and the
damage that it was doing to America's
national security and foreign policy
interests how it was working at in
opposition not in support of US policy
objectives ambassador Jovanovic had a
well-earned reputation as a fighter of
corruption and she was working with
Ukraine to get Ukraine to fight
corruption and so what does this
irregular back-channel sanctioned by the
President do it seeks to remove someone
fighting corruption in Ukraine by
employing a vicious smear campaign in
which the State Department at the
highest levels that knowledged had no
merit whatsoever that smear campaign
orchestrated by this irregular channel
was successful in removing a US
ambassador and touring her reputation of
course you see the president's comments
about the ambassador in the call record
we also released the testimony today of
ambassador mckinley another career
diplomat and public servant someone who
was asked by the secretary of state to
come back and assist the State
Department at a very difficult time for
the department and what is so striking
about his testimony is the degree to
which he sought to get the State
Department to issue a support for
own ambassador and how those repeated
efforts were rebuffed but you also see
in reading his transcript his growing a
alarm at the degree to which the
apparatus of the State Department itself
was being used to seek political
information for a political purpose by
the president United States and others
and you see that these are two of the
principal reasons that caused this
career public servant to decide that he
must resign his office as he did we will
be releasing further transcripts
tomorrow we are scheduled to release the
transcripts of ambassador Volker and
ambassador song 'ln and we will continue
to release the transcripts in an orderly
way we continue to allow witnesses the
opportunity to review their transcripts
we continue to make redactions for
private information or personally
identifiable information but we will
continue to release the transcripts and
we will soon although I can't give you
the timetable be moving to open hearings
as well and I'm happy to respond to a
couple of questions we're not going to
delay our work that would merely allow
these witnesses and the White House to
succeed with their goal which is to
delay deny obstruct the lawsuit that dr.
Kupperman filed I think is on its face
without merit someone who gets a
commercial subpoena to avoid the
subpoena doesn't simply get to sue in
court to try to avoid the subpoena I
think it will undoubtedly be the case
that that lawsuit will be dismissed for
lack of standing or justiciability
but the whole point of it is to delay
and I would say this to those who would
use litigation like the White House or
others for purposes of delay to avoid
their duty which is to follow the law
and follow congressional subpoena they
should follow the example of the
courageous people that have come forward
people who worked for dr. Kupperman
people who work for John Bolton people
who have in their careers much more at
risk have shown the courage to come
forward they have not hidden behind
litigation they have not hidden behind
the White House as the witnesses today
have they've shown enormous courage and
patriotism and I would urge others to
follow their example not follow the
corrupt example out of the White House
which is seeking to obstruct this
investigation well it has been the
consistent house rule that we do not
permit agency counsel there in
particularly when we have concerns about
those agencies the statement Department
for example and this you will also see
in the transcripts I'm trying to think
if it's in the transcripts yes it's in
the McKinley transcript State Department
representatives made the claim to their
employees that they were being bullied
by the Congress and in fact the State
Department employees were concerned
about being bullied by their own State
Department and that that bullying was
being misrepresented to Congress these
are the same agency personnel that these
witnesses want to bring in and sit in on
these depositions but this isn't just a
decision that the chairs are making in
this investigation
it's the decision that trey Gowdy made
his chair it's the decision that Jim
Jordan made and his participation in the
Benghazi investigations
it's the decision McMullen he made when
he was conducting investigations this
has been the uniform policy practice of
the house
- you're gonna [ __ ] and McKinley you
anticipate bringing these individuals
back at this point I'm not going to
comment on who our witnesses will be in
the open hearings but we will endeavor
to make the decision about who the most
important witnesses are and try to
provide testimony in an orderly and way
in which the American people can
understand the nature of the allegations
and the facts involving you know what is
at the heart of this investigation and
that is the president's abuse of his
office to coerce an ally that is
fighting off Russians in our national
security interest they are fighting off
the Russians in their interests as well
to withhold vital military support from
that nation to withhold a vital meeting
from the president of that nation as
leverage to get that nation to engage in
the corrupt act of these investigations
the president believed would help his
reelection campaign we're also obviously
looking at allegations that there may
have been effort to cover up these
activities and so the witnesses that
bear most directly on those issues are
the witnesses will want to bring in
well I think you'll see as we release
more transcripts that there may have
been others involved in in those
discussions but one of the reasons we
wanted mr. Eisenberg to come in is to
find out what his role was what the role
of others was and why a transcript that
plainly did not belong in a classified
system that is meant for some of the
most secret of intelligence activities
that is covert action activities why
would a call record that the president
would have the country believe was
perfect why would it be hidden in this
classified system so clearly the White
House does not want him to testify they
do not want the American people to know
why mr. Eisenberg or others made that
decision and I think we can infer that
the reason they don't want the public to
hear from mr. Eisenberg is that it would
tend to corroborate allegations against
the president but that's the very reason
we want to bring him in and and of
course we are concerned that he as a top
lawyer in administration would engage in
the lawless act of refusing to abide by
lawful process
you